Ist das vielleicht DAS neue Atemgas für Astronauten?!
Ein US-Forschungsteam hat jetzt einen bislang
unbekannten Reaktionsweg entdeckt, bei dem
Kohlendioxid auf sehr einfache Weise in molekularen
Sauerstoff umgewandelt wird.
Anders als bei den bisher bekannten Reaktionen
ist dafür weder besonders viel Energie noch
ein zusätzlicher Reaktionspartner notwendig.
Stattdessen reicht es aus, CO2 in hohem Tempo
auf eine Oberfläche zu schießen, die selbst
nicht als Reaktionspartner fungiert.
Wie genau läuft dieser Zerfall ab und löst
diese Entdeckung vielleicht sogar das Atemproblem
künftiger Astronauten auf dem Mars?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Es ist wirklich verflixt: Anders als in der
Erdatmosphäre kommt Sauerstoff (O2) weder
in den Gashüllen unserer Nachbarplaneten
noch sonstwo im Sonnensystem in ausreichenden
oder gar großen Mengen vor.
Astronauten-Teams müssten sich bei künftigen
Langzeitmissionen - wie beispielsweise auf
den Mars - ihren Sauerstoff zum Atmen also
selbst herstellen.
Dafür kommen unterschiedliche Ausgangsmaterialien
in Frage - wie zum Beispiel Wasser, Silikate
oder auch Kohlendioxid.
Doch um letzterem seine beiden Sauerstoff-Atome
wegzunehmen, ist ein großer Energieeinsatz
und ein weiterer zusätzlicher Reaktionspartner
nötig.
So war zumindest der bisherige Wissensstand.
Doch ein US-Forschungsteam hat jetzt entdeckt,
dass Kohlendioxid auch auf deutlich einfachere
Art und Weise zu molekularem Sauerstoff zerfallen
kann.
Eine Entdeckung der Raumsonde “Rosetta”
brachte die Fachleute auf die Idee zu dieser
Forschung.
Die europäische Raumsonde hatte nämlich
in der Gashülle des Kometen “Tschurjumow-Gerassimenko”
molekularen Sauerstoff nachgewiesen.
Eine wirklich erstaunliche Entdeckung, denn
welche Reaktionen laufen in solch einer extremen
Umwelt ab, sodass Sauerstoff frei wird!
Der direkte Zerfall von CO2 in O2 und ein
Kohlenstoffatom erschien den Experten also
zunächst als äußerst ungewöhnlich.
Begründet liegt dies in der Struktur des
CO2-Moleküls, das linear ist und somit extrem
verbogen werden muss, damit sich beide Sauerstoffatome
kontaktieren.
Schnell war klar: Eine solche Umlagerung der
einzelnen Atome im CO2-Molekül würde einen
enormen Energieeinsatz erfordern.
Dazu Konstantinos Giapis, der an der Studie
beteiligt war: “Wir dachten deshalb, dass
es unmöglich ist, die beiden Sauerstoffatome
eines CO2-Moleküls auf diese Weise zu verbinden.
Man muss schließlich etwas ziemlich Drastisches
mit diesem Molekül veranstalten.“
Gesagt - getan.
Und so schoss das Forschungsteam einen Strom
aus CO2-Molekülen auf eine Goldfolie.
Das alles passierte im Vakuum und durch den
Einsatz von reaktionsträgem Gold (Gold reagiert
nur schlecht mit anderen Substanzen) konnten
die Fachleute ausschließen, dass dieses keineswegs
selbst als Reaktionspartner agieren kann oder
sogar selbst Sauerstoff freisetzt.
Und das Ergebnis war wirklich verblüffend!
Denn ein kleiner Teil der CO2-Moleküle wandelte
sich tatsächlich in molekularen Sauerstoff
um.
Genau genommen wurde allein durch die Kollision
des CO2-Einstroms mit dem Gold ein bis zwei
Prozent molekularer Sauerstoff produziert.
Und das ganz ohne Katalysator oder zusätzlichen
Reaktionspartner.
Eine Überraschung - sogar für die Fachleute
selbst.
Weniger überraschend dagegen, dass der größte
Teil an CO2 in seine Einzelatome zerfiel oder
aber zu atomaren Sauerstoff, also Ozon O und
Kohlenmonoxid.
Die genaue chemische Reaktion, die nach dem
Aufprall abläuft, beschreibt die Studie folgendermaßen:
“Als erstes kollidiert das führende Sauerstoffatom
mit einem Goldatom des Untergrunds, dann folgt
der Aufprall des CO-Molekülrests“.
So entsteht im Großteil der Fälle Kohlenmonoxid,
da das führende Sauerstoffatom durch die
harte Kollision abgesprengt wird.
Doch bei etwa fünf Prozent der Kollisionen
passiert etwas anderes: Durch den Aufprall
verformt sich das CO2-Molekül, bleibt aber
intakt.
Beide Sauerstoffatome kommen sich näher und
binden sich quasi aneinander.
Das Forschungsteam fasst seine Ergebnisse
so zusammen: “Im Verlauf dieser intramolekularen
Reorganisation bekommt das CO2 eine dreieckige
Konfiguration mit nahezu gleichen Bindungslängen
zwischen den Atomen.
Das Molekül dissoziiert zu einem freien Kohlenstoffatom
und einem O2-Molekül”.
Durch die Bindung der beiden Sauerstoffatome
wird das Kohlenstoffatom freigegeben.
Ein wirklich toller Erfolg, denn diese bislang
unbekannte Reaktion ist unter relativ simplen
Umständen möglich.
Zusammengefasst müssen die Gas-Moleküle
lediglich beschleunigt werden und auf ein
Hindernis prallen.
Dazu Konstantinos Giapsis: “Mit genügend
Tempo könnte man sogar einen Stein in etwas
CO2 werfen und man würde das Gleiche erzielen
– der Stein müsste nur etwa so schnell
sein wie ein Komet oder Asteroid im All.
Diese Reaktion könnte daher für astrophysikalischen
Umgebungen wie Kometen, Monde und Planeten
mit CO2-Atmosphären relevant sein.“
Und damit schließt sich der Kreis zur Ursprungs-Entdeckung
der Rosetta-Sonde: Auch der molekulare Sauerstoff
in der Gashülle des Kometen “Tschurjumow-Gerassimenko”
könnte so entstanden sein.
Das US-Forschungsteam jedenfalls ist sich
sicher, dass dieser neu entdeckte Reaktionsweg
auch in der Raumfahrt von großer Bedeutung
sein könnte.
Beispielsweise könnten Mars-Astronauten aus
der CO2-Atmosphäre des Roten Planeten Atemgas
herstellen.
Doch klar ist auch, dass die Ausbeute an Sauerstoff
dafür noch nicht groß genug ist.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Ist dies
schon ein Gerät, mit dem wir das Sauerstoffproblem
auf dem Mars lösen können?
Nein!
Aber es ist eine Methode, die etwas sehr Schwieriges
kann”.
Um den aktuellen Reaktionsweg effektiver zu
gestalten, soll die er jetzt mit weiteren
Reaktionswegen kombiniert werden.
So könnte die erzeugte Sauerstoffmenge gesteigert
werden.
Mission Rosetta ist revolutionär!
Dafür hier klicken.
In diesem Video erfahrt ihr mehr über diese
spektakuläre Mission.
Anschaun und natürlich Clixoom abonnieren,
falles ihr es noch nicht getan haben solltet.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!